Hi, in this problem, we're going
to look at competing
exponential.
So we have three exponential
random variables, X with
parameter lambda, Y with
parameters mu, and Z with
parameter nu.
And we want to calculate
some probability.
And the probability that we
want to calculate is the
probability that X is less
than Y is less than Z.
Now we can reinterpret this as
3 plus Poisson processes.
Because the link between
exponentials and Poisson
processes is that the
inter-arrival time of Poisson
processes are exponentially
distributed.
So you can think of X being
the time until the first
arrival in a Poisson process
with parameter lambda.
And same thing for Y is the
first arrival time of a
Poisson process with
parameter mu.
The same thing for Z and nu.
And so in that interpretation, X
less than Y less than Z, you
could interpret as a race,
meaning that X finishes first
followed by Y and then
Z comes in last.
So with that interpretation,
let's see if we can calculate
what this probability is.
We can rewrite this probability
as a combination
of two things occurring.
One is that X is less than the
minimum of Y and Z. And then
the other is that Y
is less than Z.
So what is this first
event mean?
This first event means that
X comes in first.
And it doesn't matter whether
Y comes in second
or Z comes in second.
So we first say that X has to
come in first which means it
has to beat the better of Y and
Z. And then that combined
with the fact that Y does better
than Z is the same
thing as saying that
X is first, Y is
second, and Z is third.
And now, let's try to argue
using Poisson processes, that
these two events are actually
independent.
So this event occurring means
that X is smaller than Y and
Z. So let's take these Poisson
processes, and because these
random variables are assumed to
be independent, these are
independent Poisson processes.
So we can merge them.
So let's merge these two.
And we'll get a Poisson
process that has
rate mu plus nu.
And we can also merge this
first one and that one.
And we'll get another Poisson
process with predator lambda
plus mu plus nu.
So in that context, what does
it mean that X is less than
the minimum Y and Z?
It just means that in this
merged process, the first
arrival came from
the X process.
In that case, if that's true,
then X is less than minimum Y
and Z. Well, let's say that
event does occur that the
first arrival is from
the X process.
Now we're interested in what
the order of the second two
arrivals are.
Is it Y first and then Z?
Or Z first and then Y?
Well, it doesn't matter
because of
the fresh start property.
Because after this arrival
comes, and say it is from the
X process, the Poisson processes
start anew, and
they're still independent.
And so what happens after that
is independent of what
happened here, when X arrived.
And so whether Y came first
followed by Z, or Z came first
followed by Y is independent
of what happened here.
And so because of that, these
two events are independent,
and so when we have the
probability of the
intersection of two independent
events, we can
write that as the product of
those two probabilities.
Now, what is the probability
of this first event?
The probability that X is less
than the minimum Y and Z?
Well, we just said that that
corresponds to the first
arrival of this merge process
being from the X process.
Well, that probability
is lambda over lambda
plus mu plus nu.
So it's equal to this ratio
where the process that you're
interested in, its rate comes
in the numerator.
And then the merged rate
is on the denominator,
And what about the second one?
What's the probability that
Y is less than Z?
Well, let's go now to this merge
process where we merged
just the Y and Z processes and
see which one comes first.
Well, in that case what we want
to know is in this merge
process, what is the probability
that the first
arrival came from
the Y process?
Well, analogously, that
probability is going to mu
over mu plus nu.
And that gives us our answer.
And so we see that what looked
like a pretty complex
calculation when we
reinterpreted it in terms of
Poisson processes, it becomes
relatively easy to solve.
But this still seems like a
complicated expression.
So let's try to check
to see whether it
actually makes sense.
So one way to do that is to look
at a specific example of
the choice of lambda, mu, and
nu, and see if it actually
makes sense.
So one example is suppose that
all three of these parameters
are the same.
Well, if they're all the same
then this probability, the
first part becomes
1 over 3, 1/3.
And the second one
is 1 over 2.
And so if all three parameters
are the same, probability
becomes 1/6.
And let's see if that
makes sense.
If all three parameters are
the same, that means that
these rates, these arrival
rates are all the same.
And what that means is that any
three ordering of these
three arrivals is as likely
as any other ordering.
And what we're interested in
is the probability of one's
particular ordering happening
which is X first then Y then
Z.
But if everything is symmetric
then any of the orderings is
as likely as any other one.
And how many orderings
are there?
Well, there's three choices
for who comes in first.
Two for who comes in second.
And one for who comes in last.
So there's a total of six
possible orders in which these
three contestants, if you think
of it that way, could
finish this race.
And out of none of those, we
want the probability that one
of those outcomes happens.
And so the probability
should be 1/6.
And that's what our
formula tells us.
So as I said, in this problem,
we saw how to reinterpret
exponentials in the context of
Poisson processes that helped
us solve a--